the fact that there is thousands you
know hundreds of thousands millions of
people that watch that video I think
that's yeah that's really powerful so
how do you think the idea of putting
lectures online would really MIT
OpenCourseWare has innovated that was a
wonderful idea
you know I think the story that I've
heard is the committee committee was
appointed by the president president
vest at that time a wonderful guy and
the idea of the committee was to figure
out how a mighty could make be like
other universities market the market
work we were doing and then they didn't
see away and after a weekend and they
had an inspiration came back to the
president vest and said what if we just
gave it away and he decided that was
okay good idea so that's a crazy idea
that's uh if we think of a university is
a thing that creates a product yes isn't
knowledge right the you know the kind of
educational knowledge is and the
products and giving that away are you
surprised that you went through it the
result that it that he did it well
knowing a little bit president vest it
was like him I think and and it was
really the right idea
you know MIT as I kind of it's known for
being high level technical things and
and this is the best way we can say tell
we can show what MIT really is like
because a in my case those 18:06 videos
are just teaching the class they were
there in 26100
they're kind of fun to look at people
write to me and say oh you've got a
sense of humor but I don't know where
that comes through somehow I'd big
friendly with a class I like students
and and then your algebra the subject we
got to give this subject most of the
credit
that it really has come forward and
importance in in these years
you